Si tuvierais que invertir vuestro dinero en
un país, estoy seguro de que Venezuela sería
la última de vuestras opciones ¿Verdad?
Pues, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
el Gobierno de China no piensa como vosotros.
“China invierte 20.000 millones de dólares
en Venezuela para compensar los efectos de
la caída del precio
del petróleo”
Y no sólo hablamos del Gobierno de China
¿Os acordáis de GOLDMAN SACHS?
¿Uno de esos bancos estadounidenses que simbolizan
el capitalismo más salvaje?
Pues también han visto en Venezuela una oportunidad
para hacer más dinero.
Goldman Sachs compra 2800 millones de dólares
de bonos de deuda Venezolanos.
Habéis oído bien.
Mientras Venezuela está sumergida en una
de las mayores catástrofes económicas de
este siglo, su gobierno continúa haciendo
negocios con los mayores inversores del planeta.
Eso explica que, pese a la escasez de alimentos,
la crisis humanitaria y la pobreza extrema,
Nicolás Maduro esté comprando armamento
de última generación para mantener a un
ejército al que casi nadie podría atacar.
Un ejército que tiene más de 5000 misiles
antiaéreos de fabricación rusa.
En octubre de este año 2017, Maduro volvió
a reunirse con Vladimir Putin para negociar
una nueva compra de armas.
Mientras tanto, Venezuela sigue siendo el
país latinoamericano que más dinero ha recibido
de China.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué sentido tiene?
En lo que a finanzas se refiere, a China le
preocupan muy poco las ideologías.
Y lo mismo ocurre con los bancos estadounidenses.
Su único objetivo es ganar dinero.
Y, a simple vista, no parece que la Venezuela
de Maduro sea el mejor sitio para hacer negocios.
Así que ¿Por qué Venezuela ha acaparado
la atención de tantísimos inversores?
¿Cuál es la letra pequeña?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes… Vamos a ver un poco de historia.
UNA APUESTA DE RIESGO
Veréis, si un día queréis convertiros en
dictador de un país, oprimir a vuestro pueblo
y torturar a vuestros opositores, necesitaréis
una cosa muy importante… ¡DINERO!
Los ciudadanos de a pie pueden morirse de
hambre, pero esos soldados y policías no
pueden perder ni un dólar de su sueldo.
Lo peor que le puede pasar a un gobernante
como Maduro es que sus fuerzas de seguridad
se rebelen contra su autoridad.
Sin embargo, en Venezuela no hay empresas
privadas.
Así que no puede cobrar impuestos.
Y las exportaciones de petróleo dejaron de
dar beneficios en el año 2012.
En otras palabras, su única forma de pagar
todo ese aparato represor es pidiendo préstamos
al mercado internacional.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque la cosa no
es tan fácil como parece!
Venezuela es un país sumido en el caos económico.
Y eso significa que si les prestas dinero,
te arriesgas a que nunca te lo vayan a devolver.
En este caso, diríamos que es un bono de
ALTO RIESGO.
¿Y qué hacen los países cuando los inversores
no se fían de que vayan a devolver las deudas?
¡Efectivamente!
¡Suben el tipo de interés!
Para que os hagáis una idea, el bono venezolano
puede tener una rentabilidad por encima 10
o el 12% mientras que el alemán, que es mucho
más fiable, apenas llega al 0,5%.
¿Y esto qué significa?
Vamos a imaginar que invertimos 1000 dólares
en bonos venezolanos a 10 años.
Teóricamente, dentro de 10 años, Venezuela
nos devolverá los 1000 dólares que los hemos
prestado.
Pero mientras tanto, todos los años, recibiremos
100 dólares en forma de intereses.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque ya sé lo
que estáis pensando!
¡Esto es un negocio redondo!
¿Verdad?
Pues no del todo.
Como os decíamos antes, en Venezuela, el
riesgo de impago es muy alto.
Por ejemplo, si a los dos años de comprar
los bonos, el Gobierno se declara en bancarrota
y no puede pagarnos, habremos perdido el 80%
de nuestra inversión.
Y por eso, a pesar de las altas rentabilidades,
Nicolás Maduro lo tenía muy complicado para
vender esos bonos de deuda.
Y eso explica esta noticia.
“La compra de bonos de Goldman Sachs en
Venezuela desata protestas.
Pagó alrededor de 865 millones de dólares
en unos bonos que valen 2.800 millones de
dólares”
¿Y esto qué significa?
Pues que Goldman Sachs compró esos bonos
de deuda por la tercera parte de su valor.
En otras palabras, que teóricamente, el Gobierno
de Venezuela debería pagar 2800 millones
de dólares a Goldman Sachs pese a que estos
sólo le han sólo le han prestado 865 ¿Y
porqué Venezuela acepta esta oferta?
Primero porque necesitan dinero contante y
sonante lo antes posible.
Segundo porque tampoco esperan devolverlo.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué les prestan
el dinero si todo el mundo sabe que no lo
van a devolver?
¿Dónde esta el negocio?
Pues está en los tipos de interés.
Es decir, si Venezuela nos paga un 10% de
esos 2800 millones de dólares todos los años,
significa que en poco más de 3 años, Goldman
Sach habría recuperado esos 865 millones
que ha invertido.
A partir de ahí, todo son beneficios.
Es decir, que los inversores saben que Venezuela
puede hacer un impago.
La pregunta es ¿Cuándo?
Si Venezuela consigue aguantar durante 4 años
más sin declararse en bancarrota, la banca
gana.
Si no, pierde.
Y, lo cierto es que Nicolás Maduro era el
primer interesado en no declararse en bancarrota.
Por un lado, necesita esos préstamos para
mantener su aparato represor.
Por el otro, PDVSA, la empresa de petróleos
de Venezuela, tiene propiedades por todo el
mundo: fábricas y refinerías en países
como Haití o República Dominicana.
Si Caracas se declarase en suspensión de
pagos, muchos de estos acreedores podrían
embargar estas propiedades.
Y por eso, durante estos años, Venezuela
ha priorizado el pago de intereses de la deuda
por encima de todo lo demás.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en los últimos
años, Maduro ha pasado de tener unas reservas
de divisas de casi 50.000 millones de dólares
ahorrados a tener menos de 10.000.
Y eso explica porque revistas tan prestigiosas
como FORBES decían cosas como esta sobre
la deuda Venezolana.
Venezuela puede ser el peor país de Latinoamérica,
pero sus bonos tienen muy buena pinta.
Sin embargo… mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
por muchos esfuerzos que hiciera Maduro, la
economía venezolana no da para más.
Venezuela quiere reestructurar su deuda extranjera.
El impago aparece como una posibilidad.Tal
cual como lo oís.
Parece que tanto Goldman Sachs como todos
los demás inversores que compraron la deuda
venezolana a, precio de saldo, han perdido
la apuesta.
Sin embargo, todavía queda un acreedor al
que Nicolás Maduro no le quita el sueño.
Exactamente, hablamos del Gobierno de la República
Popular China.
EL TÍTERE DE CHINA
Como os decíamos al principio, Venezuela
es el país latinoamericano que más dinero
ha recibido de China.
Pero, a diferencia de los bancos extranjeros,
el Gobierno chino no compra bonos de deuda
en el mercado.
En su lugar, se reúnen directamente con Nicolás
Maduro y negocian un préstamo especial.
Un préstamo que no se devuelve con dinero
sino con petróleo.
De esta forma, Beijing se garantiza un suministro
continuo, pase lo que pase.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esta fórmula
también tiene sus problemas!
Como sabéis, PDVSA es una empresa hiper burocratizada,
con miles de trabajadores contratados en la
época de Chávez por puro favoritismo.
Eso significa que cada vez les cuesta más
extraer su petróleo.
Es más, en los últimos años, casi todos
esos envíos de zumo de dinosaurio, llegan
con retraso.
Sin embargo, y pese a todo, China mantiene
su lealtad hacia Venezuela.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué?
¿Qué gana China con Venezuela, ahora que
tiene problemas para suministrar petróleo?
La respuesta está en largo plazo.
Pensadlo bien, Beijing ya ha prestado 50.000
millones de dólares a Caracas.
Ahora necesita paciencia para recuperarlos.
Y estabilidad ¿Qué Nicolás Maduro necesita
unos años más para devolver sus préstamos?
¡No pasa nada!
Xi Jinping puede esperar.
Ahora bien, hay una cosa que SÍ podría arriesgar
el cobro de esa deuda.
Y esa cosa es un cambio de gobierno ¿Qué
pasaría si la oposición a Nicolás Maduro
se hiciera con el poder?
¿Seguirían tan interesados en pagar sus
deudas a esos gobiernos que han estado ayudando
al líder autoritario que les metió en la
cárcel y les torturó?
¡Son demasiados riesgos!
Y “riesgo” es la palabra menos favorita
del Partido Comunista Chino.
Eso explica cosas como esta.
Venezuela compra material antidisturbios de
fabricación China tras más de 70 muertos
en protestas callejeras.
China ha vendido más de 350 millones de dólares
en armas para que Maduro se mantenga en el
poder.
Gracias a estas gestiones, Caracas es el mejor
aliado en la región.
Básicamente, el gobierno de Venezuela se
puede convertir en el títere del Partido
Comunista Chino ¿China quiere construir infraestructuras
en Latinoamérica para completar su famosa
“ruta de la seda”?
¡Los diplomáticos venezolanos les apoyarán
sin hacer el más mínimo cuestionamiento!
¿China necesita un país para colocar bases
militares?
¡Venezuela les puede ofrecer su territorio
sin hacer la más mínima protesta!
En otras palabras ¿Existe un mejor amigo
que alguien que depende de ti para poder sobrevivir?
Juzgad vosotros mismos.
“Venezuela espera que ningún país impida
la fantástica iniciativa china de la Ruta
de la Seda”
Sin embargo, todavía queda una duda… teniendo
tantísimo poder en este país, China podría
exigir otro tipo de reformas.
Por ejemplo, podría exigirle a Maduro que
haga despidos masivos en PDVSA.
Incluso podrían tomar el control sobre todas
estas explotaciones de petróleo.
Así que la pregunta es… ¿Hasta qué punto
Venezuela puede convertirse en una colonia
china?
¿Creéis que
China se terminará quedando con el petróleo
venezolano para siempre?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Si queréis entender cómo estalló la crisis
venezolana, haced click en este otro vídeo.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribíos al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!